[Music]
there is a world to enjoy Traverse
circumnavigate let us do
[Music]
this I always thought that we should
build a world according to Bella and to
her understanding and perception of it
we're in Budapest in Hungary shooting on
many sound stages our world has been
built it's been unbelievable I could
never figure out someone specific I
thought that maybe if I put two people
that have you know very different Minds
together and if it worked out and if
they got along it would become something
very interesting we all share as
collaborators a admiration for yogos his
work and absolute love of the script I
have adventured it and found nothing but
sugar and
violence it is most
[Music]
Charming it felt sort of Timeless your
mind just starts racing of where it
could go London Lisbon Paris we've built
a composite set epic in scale yust
wanted a 1930s film but with today's
technology they worked very closely in
Tandem and I remember seeing the early
lookbooks of what they were working on
because they have two very different
sensibilities that seem to have met up
so beautifully I mean you could see they
have created a world it's Victorian it's
a dream it's gorgeous and it really does
serve the vision it really defines the
story we're telling it's got a refined
aesthetic but it's also got a sense of
humor I got scared for a second I
thought we trapped in here there's so
much originality there are fish on Bella
ceiling and there's seaweed and a mirror
that has ears and these padded silk
walls with cityscapes sewn in and I want
to copy it I I want to live in that
bedroom the functioning shops the doors
lead to actual rooms is
incredible I do think that there's a
spiritual connection that happens you
don't have to make anything up
everything's there everything that you
need is there and then there's more it
feels like something of the era but also
it has so many NDS to the future we use
the latest technology but also tapped
into some old school techniques like
Miniatures or painted backdrops and I
think it was an interesting combination
of
techniques and it is as big as it looks
even in a 4mm lens which is the widest
possible angle it's bigger than that
I've never seen anything like
it
[Music]